قد ما كان الرئيس الله يرحمه بالحكم كانت
يعني تتداول بالاوساط العراقيه موضوع وجود
اكثر من شبيه
فبيوم اللي التقينا انا وياه من دخلوه
الامريكان وانا كنت جالس اتبادر الى ذهني
بعد ان شفت وضعها يعني شكله نتيجه ظروف
المعتقل وظروف الاعتقال وما حصل الى يعني
من تعذيب نفسي وجسدي في المعتقل تبادر الى
ذهني انه الرئيس قد يكون الشبيه في هذه
اللحظه لكن اتعاملت اني وكانه الرئيس يعني
الامور كيف تيقنت انه هو تيقنت بعد ان بدا
يشرح يسرد لي احداث يعني باللقاء الاول
بده يسرد الاحداث انا اعرفها سابقا لا
يمكن ان يكون شبيه بعدين شبيه ما يمكن ان
يكون مطابق ولا حتى بدرجه 40% يعني
يتحدثون عن الشام بس كمان كان في بعض
الكلمات السر اذا صح التعبير فيما بعد
بينه وبين بعض معا في الخارج اكدت لك ايضا
فيما بعد بانه هو صدام حسين فيما بعد يعني
كلمات في السر وحتى القصائد اللي نقلت
الاناس معينين يهموه
اكدت لي بما لا يقبل شك انه لا يمكن ان
فيما بعد عرفت انه برنامج شبيه انه صحح
احد يعني المسؤولين بالدوله والمقرب من
عندها انه راح سياده الرئيس انه راح
يعني ندعي انه لك اشباه مجموعه اشباح
حمايه يعني جانب امني
يعني كانت دعايه فقط لم يكن له اي سبيل
وهو ماذا قال لك كيف اجابك عندما سالته
مباشره عن هذا الموضوع في المعتقل يعني
كان يعني يستهزئ بهذا الموضوع ما يعني ما
الى وجود او يزدري من الحديث حتى كانت
مجموعه المواكب من تطلع يعني تمويه حتى
لانه كانت ايران تحاول وفعلا يعني عملت
تفجيرات في المستنصريه عملت يعني باكثر
فاراد يعني جانب تمويهي بس